le succès de la vente directe à la ferme
olivier terre peut en témoigner
même en hiver ces légumes s'arrache et
pas seulement les côtes de bettes
aujourd'hui on propose une vingtaine de
légumes variété suivant les saisons
on a commencé la première année
admettons 150 salade tous les quinze
jours
là on plante pratiquement m'efface en
salade tous les quinze jours et au
niveau pro on part de 5000 euros la
première année
à l'année prochaine pratiquement 30 nuls
les surfaces de maraîchage sont passés
de 1 à 7 hectares en seulement trois ans
pour répondre à la demande pour que la
sphère soit rentable il fallait 100
clients par semaine
olivier père en accueillent aujourd'hui
450 en moyenne et plus de 1000 en était
au moment des cueillettes de fruits des
clients qui viennent tous pour les mêmes
raisons qui a beaucoup de choses sur
moi-même jardinières et quand j'ai
public mais ben je suis bien ici c'est
la meilleure solution
on sait que ces frais voilà c'est très
bien c'est des produits où elle a dû
terroir et puis ça fait beau c'est aussi
des agriculteurs qui ont du mal en ce
moment donc c'est bon là c'est tout
bénéfice ça n'est pas olivier qui
démentirait lui qui s'est tourné vers le
maraîchage pour faire vivre son
exploitation
le fait est qu'on avait des deux années
mauvaise en grandes cultures
donc ce qu'est céréales donc du coup il
a fallu trouver une solution pour
remédier à ce problème n'a donc l'idée
fut de rester sur siège d'exploitation
donc on a préféré se lancer dans les
légumes qui restent travailler la terre
en 2017 comme la ferme du château 8,5
pour cent des exploitations de la région
commercialiser leur production en
circuit court
elle était 2352 des initiatives
individuelles ou collectives comme le
dry fermiers de côte-d'or qui réunit
aujourd'hui une quarantaine de
producteurs parmi eux ludovic marais et
sylvain de charters de deux filets
22 filets producteur de volailles et
pisciculteurs ils sont parmi les
premiers à s'être lancé dans l'aventuré
en juin 2016 moi j'aime bien tout ce qui
est déjà ce natif et puis l'idée était
sympa de venir sur dijon pour amener à
une clientèle qu'on n'avait pas et
permet permettre d'utiliser les marchés
niches en fête le vendredi matin les
producteurs viennent livrer les
commandes passées sur internet
plus de 1000 produits sont proposés sur
le site du dry fermiers qui sert en
moyenne une soixantaine de clients
chaque semaine s'ils viennent depuis
deux ans tous les vendredis c'est à dire
qu'ils y retrouvent un intérêt de
qualité de prix rémunérateurs pour nos
fermes
on n'a aucune prétention de pouvoir
alimenter plus qu'on donnerait parce
qu'apprendre à basculer dans le volume
est aujourd'hui on privilégier la
qualité à la quantité
le panier moyen ici est de 40 euros et
ce cas précis par dessus tout les
clients c'est le côté pratique du drive
version 2.0 de l'alimentation de
proximité aujourd'hui moins de 7% des
achats alimentaires se font en circuit
court
des pourcentages en progression pour un
mode de distribution qui recrée du lien
entre producteurs et consommateurs